So my name is Logan,
Logan Engstrom.
And I'm a computer
science major at MIT.
And I'm going to talk about
the trade-offs associated
with robust machine learning.
So in machine learning
recently, there's
been an explosion in the
use of neural networks
to do image tasks.
And neural networks
have absolutely
blown away the competition
on a bunch of standard image
classification tasks.
But they all suffer from
the same vulnerability
of adversarial examples.
Adversarial examples
are examples
where you take an input and then
you perturb it very slightly.
And to a human, you
wouldn't be able to tell
the difference between
the original input
and the perturbed input.
But to the classifier,
you totally fool it.
So for example, you can
take a picture of this pig.
You can add a little
bit of perturbation that
looks like noise to a human.
And that you can't even tell the
difference between this image
and that image actually.
And it turns out that this
image with the added noise
classifies as an airplane
instead of a pig.
So this is a really big problem.
It's prevalent throughout
all state of the art image
classification models.
And there's been a
huge line of work
on trying to fix this problem.
And it turns out that the
most successful methods
for fixing this problem
for making networks that
are more robust also
caused classifiers
to have a significantly lower
accuracy than just training
naturally, and making a
model that has high accuracy
but is not very robust.
So what we set out to
do is try to figure out
if there's really a
fundamental trade-off here,
or if we're just not
doing things correctly.
So we start out with
a theoretical model.
In our theoretical
model, we essentially
show that there does
exist a setting where
there is a fundamental
trade-off between accuracy
and robustness.
And it's a pretty natural model.
And this statement is
essentially of the form
that if you reach a
certain amount of accuracy,
you have to have at most this
amount of robust accuracy,
and vise versa.
Now, we have this hypothesis.
We now move on to actually
verifying it in the real world.
Using classifiers
that are actually
used in the real world
on real world data sets.
We complete a bunch
of experiments
to verify our hypothesis.
We showed that in the
large sample regime,
if you tried to make classifiers
that are significantly more
robust than the naturally
trained classifiers,
then there is a
fundamental trade-off here.
At least in the classifiers
that we have today.
But in the small
sample regime, you
can actually see that making
classifiers more robust
actually helps.
And it essentially
acts as a form
of data augmentation to make
your classifiers even more
accurate.
But in a large
sample regime, we see
the same predicted
phenomena that we
saw in our theoretical model.
And the large sample
regime is what we really
care about in the real world.
Now, we have these
problems with training
these robust classifiers.
But are they really problems?
And is there a kind of
a silver lining here?
And so it turns out that these
robust classifiers are actually
more aligned with
human vision in terms
of how they classify images.
And this makes sense.
Because you can essentially
think of robust classifiers
as being more invariant around--
in a very small L2-norm ball--
around every single example.
And in human terms,
that's basically
like you have some
kind of image.
And then if you had a very
small perturbation to it
that a human couldn't tell
the difference between,
then a human's not going to be
able to tell the difference,
tautologically.
And so if we make it so
that these classifiers are
more robust just
around the example,
then that means
that they're going
to be more human-- they're going
to be more aligned with the way
that human vision works.
And we can actually
see this when
trying to interpret the way
that these classifiers make
decisions.
So you can see here, this
is a beetle, or an insect.
And we're trying to classify it
as an insect or a dog or a cat,
or one of any other labels.
And so with a
standard classifier
that's been trained
without trying
to make the classifier
robust, the heat map
of what the classifier
occurs about basically
looks like noise.
And so you can kind
of see that there's
like a vague
outline of a beetle.
But if you were to
see this a priori,
you'd have no idea why
this classifier was
making this decision.
But it turns out that when you
add this robustness guarantee,
the gradients become
much more aligned.
That is, the things--
the parts of the image that
the classifier cares about
becomes significantly
more aligned
with what humans
actually care about.
And so you can see here in
this gradient in this heat
map of what the
classifier cares about,
you can see that
there's essentially
an outline of the beetle.
And you can see why this
classifier made this decision.
This is the original example
that we're trying to classify.
This is the heat map of what
the standard classifier cares
about.
This right here is
the heat map of what
the adversarily-trained
robust classifier cares about.
And you can see it's
much more aligned.
We have these
experiments about showing
what happens when you have
large norm adversarial examples.
So this is basically
saying, what
happens if the
classifier-- what happens
if we can make
adversarial examples that
can be as far away as we
want from the classifier.
And so from the original input.
So instead of making it so that
the adversarial examples have
to be imperceptible
from the original image,
we're going to make it so they
can be as big as they want.
It turns out that when
you make a large norm
adversarial example starting
from this guy with a SARA
classifier, you basically
get the same monkey.
But when you try to make
the same adversarial example
from this guy going to the L2
trained adversarial example,
you actually get something
that looks like a dog.
Showing that these classifiers,
to really fool them,
you actually have
to make images that
look like the adversarial
class that you're
trying to fool them with.